Father's Day coming up guys you ready
you guys all got your pop something you
got your dad something huh
okay that was a pal audience takes 200
people that was about three people
mother's day everybody pays attention to
right they give her like a car right
Father's Day
hardly anything no one recognizes that
I'm a father and there's nothing more I
love than being left alone yeah okay
give dad what he really wants leave him
the hell alone
let him drink quietly in the basement no
sunday is Father's Day and the Trump
kids are planning to give their father a
tie yeah it'll be the first time in a
while that Trump has a tie that's not
linked to Russia
that'll never happen again I apologize
no beta this is serious stuff president
Trump is under investigation for
obstruction of justice yeah yeah that
was that was confirmed today when
President Trump said he is not under
investigation obstruction of justice
that's how you know is it really
happening
special prosecutor Robert Muller is on
the case he's the ones looking into it
experts say that if President Trump were
to fire
special prosecutor Robert Muller all
hell would break loose
yeah or as Trump calls that Thursday
that's just a normal day for him he
doesn't
this is a crazy story do you hear what
Vladimir Putin did I'm going to in a
minute I bet no you're not good night
everybody
Vladimir Putin has offered asylum to
former FBI director James Comey yeah
yeah Asylum yeah yeah yeah when she
heard Melania Trump said hey what about
me there's word story a United Airlines
employee is under fire for pushing over
a 71 year old passenger yes or is the
CEO of United put it we're back baby
[Applause]
we won't drag anymore
didn't say anything about shoving
you